how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and it's been a while
since we've gotten
anything really official from anybody at
marvel but today we have
actual new content about black widow
we have a new photo that shows her
versus task master and this is coming
from empire magazine and we also have an
interview with scarlett johansson coming
from empire magazine as well so we're
going to dive into it but first quick
announcement to celebrate 600 000
subscribers i'm giving away 10 funko
pops five on instagram and five on
twitter
so be sure to go follow me on instagram
and twitter for a chance to win a funko
pop and also this week's giveaway of
course
is a hawkeye funko pop just subscribe
like this video and comment down below
if you'd like a chance to enter and of
course so you can stay up to date on all
things relating to the marvel cinematic
universe
so as of right now black widow is still
scheduled to come out in theaters
november
6th of this year and it seems more and
more likely that it's going to stick to
a theatrical release more and more
theaters are opening up in more and more
cities currently and the christopher
nolan movie tennant
is actually doing very well a lot of
people are actually going to see the
movie and this is good news for black
widow's release
and disney's mulan comes out tomorrow on
disney plus's premiere access
so these two things will determine if
black widow goes to theaters or not if
tinnit continues to be successful and
people continue to go see movies in the
theaters and if mulan doesn't make a ton
of money that means black widow's going
to stick to her theatrical release and
another indicator of that is the
interview that was just released and
this new photo of her
fighting taskmaster now this seems to be
the scene where she's fighting him on
the bridge the two of them are fighting
taskmaster is mimicking black widow
style and they both look up at each
other at the same time we saw this in
one of the trailers so this is just a
different angle but we do get a
different look at her reaction on her
face
she seems very confused because
taskmaster's whole deal is that he can
mimic and copy a person's fighting style
just by watching it one time
and of course as we've seen in the
trailers he's been watching her for a
while now he's been studying her footage
and fighting techniques since iron man 2
or at least
the footage of her fighting is all the
way back from iron man 2.
it's called science taskmaster but she
looks extremely surprised because
obviously he knows
every one of her moves so when she's
fighting him he's able to pretty much
defeat her pretty easily
and not to mention we have seen from the
teaser trailer and the official trailer
he also fights like other avengers as
well
captain america hawkeye black panther
spider-man so not only is she probably
super surprised that he's fighting like
her and he's deflecting each and every
one of her moves but he's also fighting
like her teammates so that's gonna be
the big surprise and shock on her face
that we see right here in this photo now
we also do have a little bit from the
interview with scarlett johansson and
empire magazine while scarlett johansson
was speaking with empire magazine she
shared her thoughts on some of the
marvel studios's movies
feministic themes and she said i think
this film
in particular is very much reflective of
what's going on in regards to the time's
up
movement and the metoo movement it would
be such a miss
if we didn't address that stuff if this
film didn't take that head on
i think particularly for kate it was so
important for her to make a movie
about women who are helping other women
who lift other women
up out of a very difficult situation
someone asked me if natasha was a
feminist
of course she is it's obvious it's kind
of an asinine question
now based off of everything that we've
seen so far about the black widow film
it doesn't seem like it's going to be
very much
in your face about everything but more
along the lines of setting up strong
female characters that people can look
up to
and definitely from the sounds of this
it seems like we're going to get a lot
of scenes where
her and elena and molina all work
together
and will be helping each other and
sacrificing for each other
all throughout the movie although
spoiler alert right here if you don't
want to know any potential spoilers you
should click away now
although molina is widely speculated to
be
the actual villain of the film it's
expected that she is the person that is
actually in charge of the red room and
is actually the person in charge of
taskmaster
but if she is maybe she turns good by
the end and helps out natasha
and elena but that's our new info about
the black widow film again depending on
how this week goes at the movie theaters
and with mulan releasing today we should
get a better picture of whether or not
black widow is going to go to theaters
or straight to streaming
video on demand but in the meantime let
me know what you think about this new
still and let me know what you think
about what scarlett johansson had to say
about the movie in this interview with
empire magazine thank you all so much
for 600k
truly from the bottom of my heart it
means everything to me don't forget to
follow me on twitter and instagram for
those giveaways and don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest
mcu news as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
you